[Music]
hallo YouTube just love us and my
friends this is grunge in here welcome
to the seventh episode of most attacking
chess game whether you are beginner or
the title player these games will teach
and taste your attacking as well as
technical skills throughout the video at
certain point I am going to ask you to
pause the video and find out the best
move in the position if you match with
the move played in the game or even the
best move in the position then you have
to score 10 points otherwise you will
score only zero point and then we are
going to sum up your points and that
will tell you the story where exactly
your tactical skill lies the game I have
picked is a tribute to the Grandmaster
Timur Gurov who has recently create a
world record by playing blindfold
against 48 player the good point is he
scored 38 point five out of 48 games
which is more than 80 percent ratio
marked as Salman who is white in this
position start with the move d4 and Gera
responded with the Moon d5 and after the
move c4 we have E 6 so the Queens gambit
declined why continue here with the move
Knight to c3 now as for the situation
the most frequently moves played over
here our Knight to f6 leading to the
Queens gambit declined and also c6 which
leads to the semi Slav defense but
Grandmaster was in really attacking mode
and he played one of the most aggressive
setup starting with the MU
sea far this is known as tirage defense
here the mainline continue with the MU C
captures D file now the proper tirage
move over here is he kept his d5 which
leads to some isolated queen pawn but in
return black get tremendous activity
instead of all this girl choose a gambit
line and here he captured the d4 pawn
attacking the knight white of course
take this pawn and now comes Knight to
c6 attacking the Queen Queen to Deva
and after pawn captures curry note
Knight captures defy is not a good move
over here so the best move as for the
theory is Queen captures defy afterwards
black continue here the move Bishop to
d7 personally in the whole default
complex
I think this gambit which is known as
born handing Shara gambit is the most
Agassi one and there are many games
where black crushes white within 25 or
30 moves so if you are looking for an
alternative which will give you a very
attacking game then I think this gambit
is a very good choice for you now the
main move over here is Knight to f3 but
in this game why I decided to surprise
his opponent and he played the Bishop to
d2 no matter black continued here with
the move Knight to f6 and once again if
y wants to play a very safe game then he
can play Queen to b3 or Queen to D 3
which is less riskier than chilly played
in the game that is Queen to g5 I guess
the only reason why s Edmund played the
MU Queen to G Phi because he want to
take his Grandmaster opponent out of the
theory book and create a complex game
where White has all the chances now
black who so far played in a true gambit
style continued his attacking style and
offered another pole with the move
Bishop to e7 white took the challenge so
he captured the g7 pawn so you can
already see that black pawn structures
are completely ruined and on top of
everything white is a clear to point up
but this is the idea of this gambit if
you carefully look at the white position
White King side position is completely
blocked up so it will take a hell lot of
time to take those species in the cave
here black continue with his energetic
style with the Mook to g8 attacking the
Queen Queen to f6
and now Queen join into the party with
the move Queen to b6 attacking p2 here
white played the obvious move
which he was aiming for that is
queenside castle defending the b2 and
now we reach to the first critical
position kindly pause the video and find
out what is the best move and
disposition okay I hope you find this
wonderful move castle on the Queen side
so Grand Master is wasting no time in
peace development and he wants to attack
White King as quickly as possible
now instead of castle you might think
hang on
can't we take this f2 pawn which is
already a loose well first thing you
should know that whenever you are
playing a gambit you are not playing for
equalizing the material or giving back
the initiative and that is the clear
case over here because Queen to f2
allows y to develop his piece with the
move Knight to f3 and now not only that
Queen is misplaced but that will give
all the time to the Y to develop his
King side pieces same goes for the move
Knight to g4 as it looks very attractive
as it is attacking Queen and attacking
f2 but afterwards next reply that is
Queen captures at 7 grabbing the 3rd
pawn and attacking the rook and here the
best reply for the black is to castle on
the Queen side and after the move Knight
to h3 not only white defend everything
but I don't think so black has enough
compensation for his lost pawns so
that's why as for the scenario Castle is
the best move in this position now
indeed black is threatening the move
Knight to g4 so white has to stop it and
in fact he did with the move f3 so not
only stopping knight intrusion but what
is planning to play the movie for and
liberate his King side pieces ok black
continue here with the move Bishop to e6
not only opening the D file for the rook
but those monster bishops are looking at
white coincide white continue as we
expected he played the movie phone and
we reach to the second important point
of the game where you have to decide
what you are going to do next
well congratulations if you find this
move that is 95 so not only black
centralize that night but that night is
coming quickly on the queenside now this
is not the best more in the game the
best more in the game is rook to g6
which Believe It or Not wins a piece
because after Queen to e3 and Bishop to
c5 black wins apiece for the to pawn and
this position is advantageous to the
black nevertheless night to Aoife has
its own venom here white continue with
the move Knight to h3 and now this is
the most important point of the game
because as White has the only one Bishop
to develop and he's on the verge of
consolidating his position so as a black
you have to find some concrete attacking
blow kindly take as much as your time
and find out the only move which gives
black and advantageous position are you
ready
have you seen this move Shakalaka boom
boom well personally when I gone through
this game I didn't find that moon
what a wonderful mood to play in the
game first the important point why it
cannot take this rook the simple reason
is after night Shaq fight key is going
to be checkmated and if white cannot
take the rook then that means that black
group is posted on the seventh rank and
now I can create some very concrete
threads over here after a long think
white continue here with the MU King to
be one so his idea is that now Knight to
d3 is not a check and maybe in some line
where it can capture back that rook
so now ball is in your court how you
going to respond to this move well you
are really a super attacking chess
player if you find this poo that is
Knight cactus efore BAM
now in order to understand this move the
first thing you need to notice is before
nightcaps is efore there is an x-ray on
this loose queen so that means if you
can get rid of this two-piece then white
is in severe danger surprisingly enough
black has two pieces hanging but there
is only one more order which keep white
in the game which in fact esselman
didn't find it now before I move on what
I like you to do is you need to
calculate all the variation from the
black perspective what happens after
Knight takes Knight pawn takes Knight
and Bishop captures rook and I will give
you guarantee that you will be thrilled
by the black options before we start
there's one thing I like to mention over
here that instead of Knight captures
efore which is a human move computer
suggest that Knight 2 D 3 is even better
but in the game it is very hard to see
what exactly going on in the position
however if you find this move
congratulations
you can also score full points let's see
the fascinating move Knight captures
efore now the first point you should
notice is when white capture this night
it is all night then black will continue
here with the move rook G captures D 2
so destroying the defender of the Queen
for example if white capture with the
night or the rook so let's say Knight
captures D 2 then Bishop 2 fi will NAB
the Queen if rook captures V 2 then
after Bishop captures a to check once
again white will lose his queen so the
only good move over here is Queen
captures D 2 but then after rook
captures rook captures and Queen to e5
although material is balanced over here
that is let's say white has to look for
the Queen
but the problem over here for the white
perspective is this King side PCs are
pathetically placed and that will give
all the time for the black to arrange
his attack on the King side
okay so it turns out that night kept his
efore is a disaster zone for the white
so how about if we capture with the app
pawn well here the MU is very obvious
you have to destroy the defender of the
Queen that is rook G captures d2 and now
a white capture with the rook then after
Bishop captures a two white will simply
lose a queen so that's not good so
accordingly Queen captures d2 is forced
afterwards we are going to take with the
rook and after rook takes we pretty much
leads to the same position which we have
seen in the last night captures a four
line the only difference over here that
white knight is sitting on c3 where it
is well protecting the a2 and that's why
this position only give slight advantage
to the black in fact this is why it
should have done in the game in the game
why I decided to go for the third option
that is Bishop captures g2 but this is
just asking for it final move of the
game and what it is you need to find out
where here black played a simple but
very effective move Knight capture c3
and white simply resigned what a
miniature by grey just in 17 moves a
player strength of international master
has been completely crushed now in case
if you are wondering why white resign
here are the few lines
if white capture this night then the
simplest is you first fall take this
rook with a check and after rook takes
we have Bishop to a5 which nabbing the
White Queen so that's not good and
instead of capturing the night if White
King try to run away for example King to
e1 then black get winning attack after
Knight captures rook captures Knight to
c4 attacking to sports and after Queen
to g7 defending the b2 black has this
effective move Epps's
which will allow black
to execute his attack very very smoothly
now can give this one check that is
Quinn check but after Bishop to d8 in
fact that is no skip okay so it's time
to sum up your points and find out what
is your score out of 50 points well if
you are scoring 40 or more than that
then congratulations your tactical
skills are very sharp and you are just
thinking like a grandmaster if you are
scoring 30 then there are few technical
aspects you are missing in your game
which you just need to walk on it but if
you are scoring 20 or less than that
then you seriously need to improve your
tactical chess skills and that means you
need to see more of this kind of
attacking chess games well I hope you
enjoy and learn this wonderful attacking
chess game thank you for watching this
video feel free to like subscribe and
comment on my video and I'll meet you in
my next episode very soon bye and take
care
noth-nothing yeah okay a 3b for gaining
space on the queenside so that is one
plant and the second plant is